[Music]
welcome to
our first the week in 60 minutes for
2021
from spectator tv recorded on thursday
january the 7th we hope that you were
able to have a wrestle christmas despite
the circumstances now
we had planned to start with the latest
on the vaccine roll
out but we'll turn first to last night's
extraordinary mob violence
on capitol hill as congress was
acknowledging
joe biden as victor in the presidential
election of 2020.
i'll be speaking to the spectators
american team about what it means for
donald trump
the new administration and the state of
america
back in dear old blighty the latest wave
of coronavirus has surprised
everybody in its ferocity 150 brits now
have the virus
1 in 30 londoners with some hospitals
running out of capacity
unlike previous lockdowns however we now
have a vaccine
indeed several and the race is now on to
vaccinate the
13 million most vulnerable before
february is out
the spectator team will bring you the
latest covert breakdown
and political analysis we'll also be
joined by jeremy hunt the former
conservative
health secretary remember if you
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel for free
you never miss another episode just
click the subscribe button
at the bottom right of the screen now
and a very special thanks
to charles stanley for their continued
support of the week in 60 minutes this
year
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange
and we're delighted to be partners
first america it looked like the
storming of the palace by the mob
in some banana republic in fact it was
happening
in the heart of american democracy the
scenes were shocking but perhaps not
surprising
president trump had been egging on his
hardcore supporters for weeks
with nonsense about a fraudulent stolen
election
and the need to take a stand but it's
surprising given how well last night's
protest was signposted
without totally unprepared law
enforcement was
to deal with the assault on capitol hill
their inability to defend the citadel of
american democracy
when around the world warming the
cockles of every authoritarian heart
that despises the democratic process the
mob managed to occupy
the senate chamber and the offices of
senior lawmakers
joe biden called it sedition and it's
hard not to agree with him
donald trump was lukewarm in urging his
rioters
to resist and it's hard not to see him
as the author of what happened last
night he is just some of what went down
brilliantly documented by itv's robert
muer
usa usa usa
usa for four years we have witnessed
turmoil in america
but nothing quite like this
the pro-trump crowd fought with the
police
trying to break through their lines
intoxicated by the unlikely prospect of
reversing america's election outcome
we watched as a standoff continued for
at least an hour
tear gas canisters were fired from the
very stage on which joe biden will be
inaugurated
but for capitol hill police officers
this was a losing battle
this is exactly what was feared but in
no way is this a surprise it has been
fueled
by the president's rhetoric and it's
increasingly clear
this election has not healed the wounds
it has simply
amplified them
we follow the aggrieved and infuriated
trump supporters
as they stormed the building
through broken windows and doors they
had forced open
[Applause]
[Music]
and for a few heady moments they felt
they had won a precious victory
[Music]
[Applause]
what's the purpose of storming congress
itself because
they work for us they don't get to steal
it from us
they don't get to tell us we didn't see
what we saw
we respect the law we were good people
the government did this to us we were
normal good
law-abiding citizens and you guys did
this to us
we want our country back we are
protesting for our freedom right now
that's the difference what's the purpose
of storming congress
[Music]
they reached and entered the speaker's
office itself
although nancy pelosi and other
lawmakers had already been evacuated to
safety
there you go there you go brother as we
filmed
protesters tore down pelosi's nameplate
and so here we are
right now inside the halls of congress
this is exactly what
so many anticipated and yet the capitol
hill police
are doing their best but failing to
control the situation
that was robert muer giving you meaning
to reporting from the front line there
for itn
we thank itn for that footage no
in washington dc a new day has just
started so let's go there
straight away to our washington ender
editor amber athey amber
uh what's it like the morning after the
night before
it's a very bizarre feeling here in dc
it seemed like
everyone feels very somber about what
happened
i actually attended the march yesterday
to cover it for the spectator
but my group ended up leaving around 12
30 in the middle of trump's speech so
well before
any of this mob rioting started to occur
well before people started marching on
the capitol and at that time
everything was incredibly peaceful i
mean even when rudy giuliani
made this comment about trial by combat
first of all it was incredibly hard to
hear the speakers and second i didn't
see people react to that no one seemed
to be getting riled up by comments like
that
everyone to me seemed like they were
just happy to be around
fellow like-minded trump supporters and
that was very much the vibe as we got on
the metro and headed home
people were just tired from the day and
felt like they
they had a good time they were glad that
they had come across country for this
we ended up meeting up with several
other people at a
at a bar later and there were trump
supporters filing in throughout the day
who legitimately had no idea what was
even going on at the capitol and were
stunned when they saw the scenes
unfold on cable television and and
perhaps one of the
craziest or most uh stunning moments
for me was watching several bartenders
at this restaurant crying as they
watched what was happening in their
nation's capital
so i think everyone is uh very concerned
about
what happens next very concerned about
the fact that
the capitol building was able to be
breached so easily with seemingly
very little police presence uh and again
just a very weird mood here
well it's not unusual for peaceful
protest to end in violence that happens
with left-wing and right-wing
demonstrations
but in this case amber what went wrong
what turned
the peaceful protest you saw peaceful
demonstration
into these scenes of violence and
basically assaulting capitol hill
yeah it seems to me like what happened
here is a culmination of
uh really a sad state of affairs in
american society
and this could have happened with any
group in my opinion because
over the summer we had months of riots
a literal occupation in portland for
over a hundred days
a an autonomous zone in seattle where
people were shot and killed
and all of that violence was actually
cheered on by a lot of our political
elites cheered on by the media
and that type of violence has been seen
to be rewarded in american society over
the past couple of years
and so these people who have been stuck
in lockdown for eight months
very much in social isolation very
little aid given to them by the
government
now they're of the belief that in a a
democratic election was stolen from them
they go down to the capitol building and
it's like a powder keg just waiting to
be ignited
from people who have felt
disenfranchised for so long
they have this opportunity in front of
them where they can finally get the
political elite to listen to them
there are maybe five police officers
holding them back from it
and that's and that's exactly what you
saw what happened is people
were at the gates of of the
you know the political establishment and
said this is it this is our time
why were the law enforcement authorities
so unprepared
that's a question that everyone is
confused by you know when i first went
into the march
there were streets blocked off six seven
if not ten blocks away from this protest
which was
much smaller than the million megamarch
that took place shortly after the
election
and there were police by the barricades
on these streets
and so it seemed very bizarre to me that
there were fewer police
at the capitol it seemed than were in
the surrounding streets
in front of businesses and other
non-governmental buildings
it it was a very odd thing to see i
don't really understand why they weren't
prepared for this
and you know dc has a very short
memory this happened in 2018 where
granted there weren't people clashing
with police officers but during the
kavanaugh hearings
the women's march orchestrated a march
on the capitol
at that time the police were well
prepared they had barricaded
the area very well there were numerous
police officers
so instead what the women's march did is
they entered the hart senate building
there were thousands of people in the
atrium of the heart senate building
during the kavanaugh hearings to the
point where they actually had to delay
them
and 300 arrests were made on that day so
this is not entirely unprecedented
and you have to question why exactly the
police were not prepared for something
like this to happen when there are 20
000 people
on the national mall freddie gray our
u.s
editor uh will president
trump's years of the white house now
not be forever tainted by the scenes we
saw last night
i think i think they probably will be
now and uh i keep thinking to myself
or keep trying to do some thought
experiment with myself let's imagine
that in the days after the election not
necessarily on the night because it was
very confused that trump had
accepted the result and said you know
it's a tough one to take
uh but i congratulate my opponent joe
biden
and then he probably could have tweeted
you know nastily about it afterwards but
everyone would have been
impressed that he'd behaved with some
dignity and he would have positioned
himself having just won 70 million votes
he would have positioned himself as a as
a one-term president so a failure in
some ways
but somebody who could well come back in
2024 and win if he wanted to
and could perhaps even um have had a
sort of graceful retirement
but he took the other road uh and at the
moment it looks like it's a disastrous
road to have taken uh for him and for
the country
kate andrews our economies correspondent
president american in the uk
uh has this not seriously undermined
any hopes mr trump might have harbored
of coming back in 2024
i think it has andrew because it is
going to be impossible to shake off the
reputation now
as somebody who quite directly was
trying to undermine
america's democratic processes and
regardless of where you fall on the
political spectrum
it is a founding principle in american
society it's it's a core value for
voters that we are transparent and fair
in that
we respect results and the problem for
the president is that
he has taken every pathway possible to
try to overturn it he went to the states
he went higher he went to the supreme
court and everybody has thrown out his
complaints he had a right to take them
but they have not been
upheld and i think it is impossible it
absolutely impossible to separate the
president from the scenes that we saw
last night he has been stoking division
and doubt
amongst his supporters for months now
telling them that the election result
wasn't fair and their reports that
senator mitt romney once the senators
were put into a safe space was yelling
at senators like ted cruz who have been
embracing the president's remarks saying
this is what you've gotten essentially
this is what happens when you
lie to people about the results of the
election and you know that starts and
stops really
with donald trump that's not to say
other republicans aren't responsible
frankly i think they are but if we're
going to place blame
it is with the president and donald
trump likes the conversation to be about
him
uh whether it's when certainly when it's
good news but if it's bad news and he
makes a mistake well you know that has
to sit with him and his legacy too
amber is it not also bad news for those
republicans
like senator ted cruz who have been
giving heir to trump's allegations of
election fraud they seem to have been
backing him
this is surely going to be a huge
embarrassment for them too
yeah it's going to be difficult for
senators like ted cruz and josh hawley
who
i actually think took a fairly
reasonable position in the way that they
responded to the president's allegations
for example josh hawley was basically
only challenging the results in a couple
of states
and calling for an investigation into
alleged fraud or
last-minute changing of the rules but
wasn't outright stating that the
election was a fraud and that it needed
to be overturned
but now because of the scenes at the
capitol because of
the way that this all shook out it's
practically impossible very very
difficult for these people to stake that
claim now
and that's why you saw many senators
yesterday
reversing their decisions to challenge
the results
because they didn't want to be
associated with any sense of violence
freddie how does the republican party
move on from donald trump
if he allows them to to move on
will there be a sense a lot of
republicans start to realize that rather
than being an asset he's actually a
loser
he lost the white house by seven million
votes
huge number he lost the house he's now
lost the senate
as well and he's lost america's
democratic reputation after last night
well there is all that but then there's
also the fact that he does have
huge support among the base
it's a it's a problem for the republican
party if they want to disassociate
themselves from trump's legacy
and i think what you've had in the
republican party the last four years of
daniel mccarthy one of our writers
called it a cyborg and it's a sort of
combination of an
uncomfortable republican party and the
trump movement
and it just about sort of struggled
through the trump years but it was never
a comfortable alliance and it never sat
well together and we saw in the
uh senate runoff races in georgia it
doesn't win
uh kelly loffler's almost perfect
example of a trump republican cyborg
uh it's insincere
it puts off working-class voters in the
end
and it loses elections but let me come
back to you because i don't
really say see the way forward with the
republican party at the moment because
it's like trump is like this huge
shadow overhanging them i can see where
in a number of policy areas
mr trump leaves a legacy uh
concentration on jobs for blue collar
workers a tougher line
with china a new way of getting peace in
the middle east
i can see all that and the republicans
will want to bank that
and make that part of their future
appeal
but how do they do that and somehow
managed to ditch
mr trump
yeah that's the most difficult question
moving forward because
you know i've always said that i thought
trumpism was able to be separated from
the person trump
that obviously becomes a lot more
difficult with the way that he's handled
this election and of course the scenes
that happened at the capitol yesterday
trump can either choose to fade away
after this
not wanting to be scarred forever by the
scenes that we saw yesterday
or he's going to try to stay around and
continue to be a republican king maker i
think the latter option
shows a bit of cowardice because it's
ultimately his supporters who he hung
out to dry
he told these people to walk to the
capitol and that he was going to be with
them
while he went back into the white house
and and hid in safety
so for him to encourage these people
repeatedly
telling them that mike pence could
ultimately save the republic
and and encouraging this type of
aggression towards the
towards politicians he has to take the
blame for that and he has to consider
if he even cares about the republican
party which i think maybe he probably
doesn't
then he has to consider moving forward
how he's going to
make it possible for the republican
party to continue to embrace his
principles
moving forward and right now it seems
the best option is for him to sort of
fade from memory
but he likes kate the limelight and
he may not just fade that may be best
for the republican parties they try to
rebuild
but he may not go away quietly he could
hang around and really be the
goal in the nest because you know he
could if he wanted to it'll be
interesting to see what extent the media
still gives him
attention if anything i'd say it's
already gone quieter up until really the
past few days
in relation to trump and his opinions as
people pivot to president
elect joe biden and but again this is a
decision for the republican party
because
in america we don't have party leaders
in the same way if a party isn't in
power
and for everything donald trump has done
it has essentially led to
nothing for the coming years because the
democrats have taken back control
of the oval office and of congress the
republicans now have the opportunity
with no real leader
technically in charge to start soul
searching
debating amongst each other figuring out
what went wrong figuring out why a
republican party of abraham lincoln and
ronald reagan
was so willing at the smallest sniff of
power to hand over
everything to donald trump to never
challenge him when he put
his foot over the line um if they allow
him to continue to cloud that debate and
to dominate that debate they're going to
be in a more difficult position and
in 2024 and i agree with you andrew you
know this is the moment to separate
policies from the man to figure out what
was actually good for the american
people
and what donald trump thought was good
for him
if they can keep the former and remove
the latter they've got a real shot
even to take back the senate in a few
years time
but if donald trump continues to
dominate i fear for the republican
party's future not just in the next few
years but
possibly over decades they could do real
irreversible damage
meanwhile freddie uh the democrats
control
of the executive branch and uh both
houses in the legislature uh and i would
suggest that that is
particularly the senate that is down to
donald trump he lost georgia
uh it was winnable for the republicans
the further you go down the ticket the
more republican
georgia still is but that telephone call
to the secretary of state of georgia
i mean it was like a a banana republic
dictator leaning on one of his
lieutenants to find 11 750 votes it was
a most remarkable conversation and if
you tell your own supporters
that it's a fraudulent election that the
elections can't be trusted
you shouldn't be surprised if they don't
turn out and bother to vote
well andrew yes that was a ridiculous
conversation
a lot of people said that the washington
post had edited it to make it sound a
lot worse
than it was but if you listen to the
whole thing um
it is actually pretty bad it's pretty
awful and trump sounds
desperate and sort of strangely hopeless
um but i would say the the opportunity
for the republican party
in the next few years is going to be the
fact that the democrats
now control the executive or will soon
control the executive and the
legislature
this means that they will have almost
total power
unbridled power in congress
and it means that the excuse that the
democrats have had that barack obama
used a lot that joe biden also uses a
lot
that they would transform america in the
progressive direction that a lot of
their base want them to go
were it not for the republicans is gone
uh and so they will now have to
accommodate uh their progressive base
and this will mean they are way to the
left of the american mainstream
on a lot of issues and it will be
interesting to see
how uh the electorate react to that in
2022 and
moving ahead to 2024. if the republican
party can come up with a coherent
response to that then they could
win again quite soon it's always
dangerous though amber when the
opposition party depends on government
to completely screw up in order to get
back into power
i mean there was an opportunity here
with the democrats with a moderate
president in the white house a smallish
democrat majority in the house it come
down a bit after the
november election and and a smallish
republican majority in the senate that
kind of combination
could have led to quite centrist
moderate government overall
in the united states but thanks to mr
trump's
cavalier approach to georgia it's lock
stock and barrel to the democrats now
they're in charge
sure and i i wouldn't say that trump is
solely to blame for georgia i think it's
a bit more
complicated than that mitch mcconnell
certainly bears some blame there as well
for refusing to
pass the two thousand dollar stimulus
check when you look at polls in georgia
that was a very popular issue with
voters
i think it was something like 75 percent
of voters
agreed with having two thousand dollar
stimulus checks
so if you already have this situation
where maybe republican turnout is
being suppressed a bit because people
feel that their vote's not going to be
counted
as well as perhaps independents who feel
like they're only shot at getting a
stimulus check after
eight months of a pandemic is by putting
democrats in power
then that really is a recipe for
disaster
let's finally let's just look ahead uh
the news cycle these days moves very
quickly it could be that uh
mr trump will be better memory by the
spring equinox
who knows but we will have a biden
administration and with a
majority in the house and a casting vote
of the vice president in the senate so
that's
but let's look ahead to the next couple
of months
tell me i start with you kate how do you
see
the biden administration playing out in
its first
four to six months with the senate now
it'll probably get a bigger stimulus
bill
through the congress that it would have
done if the republicans had held on to
the senate
i think we're going to see a lot more
spending on the covet crisis andrew with
less accountability
you're not going to have the senate in
in the gop's hands to at least ask
questions
about how much money is being spent not
that they've been particularly fiscally
responsible
even in the last four years but you're
going to have less debate around that
issue
i do suspect though from joe biden's
comments certainly in the past 20 hours
over the past few months that this is
not going to be a president who's out
for blood
he's going to want to point many fingers
especially at the voters that
he knows he could potentially win back
on side who who might be a bit skeptical
of him but are just looking for
a calm or a calmer and slightly more
relaxed environment in american politics
and he very much pointed the blame for
last night's chaos at the president
and at the mob itself i don't think he's
going to be pointing it
so much at the republican party and
certainly not at its voters i'm hopeful
that in the next few months we might
find a republican party that is a bit
more introspective
willing to work with joe biden to be
more moderate to be more centrist to put
off those in joe biden's party
who would like to see him tack to the
left i mean after everything that's
happened in
in the past 20 hours i can't say i'm too
hopeful but i think there is still a
chance
at some unity in coming together to
further help america
recover from this cova crisis and the
real debate might start in a year or so
when both parties are thinking about the
next election
i guess uh amber in one regard mr biden
will be pleased he now controls both
houses and the white house
on the other hand he's lost any excuses
for the left of the democrats to say
look i agree with you i'd like to do
that
but i couldn't get her through a
republican senate he you can't play that
card anymore yeah as often happens in
situations like this where parties do
control
all parts of the government there tends
to be a lot more infighting over exactly
how they're going to use that power
the same exact thing happened during the
beginning of the trump administration
when republicans
held the house in the senate and the
only thing they were somehow able to get
done
was this tax cut that was only temporary
for the middle class and permanent for
corporations
so i wouldn't expect that the byte
administration will be that much more
successful
holding all of this power and that's
where the republican party has this
opportunity
going into 2022 if they're able to
navigate
this sort of landmine now where they
have to embrace some
tenets of trumpism like nationalism and
populism
that have been very appealing to the
working and middle class
but somehow separate themselves from the
fact that he
went out on such a sour note they could
stand to do very well
in two years ready finally to you what
are
what's the first major pitfall that
faces the biden administration
well i mean i i think um that the
pandemic is obviously
uh the big problem they're going to
grapple with and they tend to be very
very locked down minded
i don't know how well that will go down
with middle america
and i think the key figure really is
going to be kamala harris who now
with a 50-50 split senate is going to be
deciding
the most controversial issues in america
the most controversial legislation in
america
i'm not actually sure that's a position
she might want considering
we think she has her eyes on the white
house possibly
as soon as 2023 she'll have to spend a
lot of time in that senate uh seat
yes given that it's all going to be on a
knife edge all the votes you have to be
there to be the casting
uh vote which may inhibit as you say her
other activities let's leave it there
for the moment after these horrible and
historic scenes in capitol hill
last night 13 days to the inauguration
uh now let's hope there is no more
violence in the run-up to that and the
inauguration itself goes off the way
inaugurations are meant to go off after
all
the hallmark of democracy is the
peaceful
transfer of power that's what makes it
different
from every other form of government
ready kate amber
thanks for joining me today remember if
you subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel for free
you'll never miss another episode just
click the subscribe button at the bottom
right of the screen now
now back home in dear old blighty the
covert situation is worsening and
quickly
there's a lot to unpack since our last
show towards the end of 2020
the oxford vaccine rollout has started
but the government is in a race
against time infections in the uk are
almost as bad
as they were in march last year schools
are closed again
all four nations of the united kingdom
are giving stay at home
orders there are two new strains both of
which seem
vastly more infectious if not
necessarily more toxic
than what we've been used to president
nelson the spectator editor is on hand
to give us the latest overview on graphs
from our new
daily updated data hub which is a must
read for those who want to keep up with
what's happening on covent
fraser over to you thank you andrew well
since the start of the pandemic we at
the spectator have been
keeping track of all the relevant data
not just the
infections and deaths but other things
that decide policy like
how busy are the intensive care units
how full
are the hospitals and we thought that
rather than um
normally you see these graphs when a
journalist wants to show you them
plonked in the middle of an analysis
normally um backing up the journalists
points
we thought we'd make this available for
everybody so you can have a look at your
own
figures people can see and perhaps spots
trends
which journalists might be missing and
i'll give you an example quite often
we're used to seeing
every day there were so many new
infections yesterday there were 20 000
40 000
but those figures are hugely affected by
the number of tests taken
now of course recently we've seen a
trebling sometimes the quadrupling and
the numbers of tests taken
every day which has led some people to
say well maybe the increase in covet
cases
isn't as high as the figures say so
let's look at our first graph for
example the office for national
statistics will tell you how many
infections there are in britain and at
any one time
and it does this by doing a sample now
this sample shows that while
back in september there was very little
covered in britain at the last count
there were 1.2 million
people estimated to have covered at any
one time
now that is something like 1 and 50 of
the population
when you've got curvature at levels
you're sure that hospitalizations and
deaths will
surely follow now that is a pretty grim
chart one that's only moving upwards
and it raises an interesting question
why if the situation is so bleak
are ministers so relatively optimistic
when james forsyth and i went to see
matt hancock a couple of days ago to
interview him for this week's magazine
and we left just struck by how upbeat he
is how convinced he is
that we're just a few weeks away from
this he was using phrases like
cry freedom for the end of restrictions
so what makes them so optimistic sure
they're vaccinating but we've only
managed to do one and a half
a million vaccines so far more than
anybody else in europe
but certainly a far cry away from the 40
million
adults there are in this country have a
look at the priority list
those who are in care homes they're
getting vaccinated first
and they make up about 1 million people
then it's the over 80s
they're second in line then those age 75
and over
70 and over and then the rest
so there the thing about covid is that a
large number of fatalities
come from a relatively small number of
people so these are the figures
i'm about to show you that are giving
government ministers their optimism
in care homes for example if you cover
just one million people
then you've covered the group
responsible for 36
of the deaths so you should in theory
have covered a third of those
most likely to die from covet in coming
months if you take that to the over 80s
and then it's 66 percent so that's
two-thirds of those likely to die
from covid and already about a quarter
of the over 80s have been vaccinated in
britain
so when you go down to the over 65
you're then
looking at about 93 so this is why the
prime minister is talking about easter
he reckons that by the middle of march
you'll have covered pretty much
four out of five people likely to die
from covid thereby downgrading the virus
from something which fills up hospitals
and causes excess deaths
into something which is more of a
headache that will put you in bed for a
few days
but will not pose a challenge or as big
a challenge
to the health service now that is of
course
um quite um a big gamble after all a
third of those in hospital or under
65. and but the other thing is that
you're looking at a system now where
the rates of hospitalization are
increasing so fast that in london this
time last month
and people in the hospital have covered
it was barely a third
of the peak but look at it now far over
that peak we're hearing reports now that
even now it looks like london hospitals
are in grave danger of being overwhelmed
so we're looking at a bit of a race
against time that's the theme of the
cover
for the magazine this week the vaccine
versus
the virus and with that andrew back to
you thanks
uh frieza so just to to clarify
the government believes that the
quickest way to
cut the death rate to cut the number of
deaths
is to concentrate on the most vulnerable
because that that will have the biggest
impact the more you vaccinate them the
more the death rate will come down from
covert
that's right and they further believe
that you can cover you know three
quarters four-fifths
of those likely to die within a few
weeks
of course it's not quite as fast as that
because the vaccine takes between two
and three weeks to have
any effect and then there's a further
three and four weeks to go with
delay between infections and the death
figures so it might be quite some time
before we see any
effect of this in the daily death toll
from covert
but why they're optimistic is they think
that it will only take a few
million vaccines as long as they can
correctly target those
risk to make a really quite considerable
difference
in the british um death toll and just
transform the debate
about covert and stop it being seen as
much
as a disease which puts people in
hospital and takes lives
but i think you just said something
that's quite important not everybody
realizes
if if you get vaccinated tomorrow
it's at least two weeks maybe three
weeks
before you are largely immune to the
virus is that right
and that's right and that's of course
after the first jab
pfizer recommends people take two jabs
to get up to 95
um but the government thinks you can get
about 70
protection from the first jab but it
takes a while for that
to happen my 90 year old neighbor for
example told me today she was going to
get her jab
on friday and was offering kindly to
babysit on friday evening
i had to say to her no it's going to be
a few weeks before it's safe for you to
go everywhere
so i do wonder if people are wrongly
thinking that once they get the jab
they're protected they should be staying
at home and shielding for
to i would say three weeks before it's
really safe
to regard yourself as protected and even
then after the first jab
you're not a hundred percent protected
there's still plenty reason for caution
well that's an important point for
anybody watching that if they do get
vaccinated particularly older people
you still go to a shield for at least a
couple of weeks up to three
uh to make sure that you are largely
immune and then you know
haven't got the full immunity or as much
as you can have
until you get the second jab it's a
great interview with the health
secretary fraser
i take his his general upbeat approach
is entirely down
to the prospects of the vaccine is that
right
that's right they're quite optimistic
they've got the army
embedded literally embedded in the nhs
and the top floor
of nhs head office there are something
like 60 uniformed
officers under the commander of
brigadier phil prosser
who is a commander of one-on-one
logistics division
so they think that they they're really
optimistic being able to deliver
vaccines as fast
as the manufacturers can churn them out
now that's quite
a big if because it's not simply a
matter of making the vaccines the oxford
one
has to lie for something like 20 days a
sterilization period
then they that just need to get approved
by the regulator
so there's logistically there's a lot
which could go wrong
also in our cover piece of the magazine
this week richard dobbs points out
that you would need a pretty good
take-up rate what happens if 20
of those invited for a vaccine don't
actually show up what happens if the nhs
don't have the addresses
or the records you can still end up with
quite a lot of people who should be
protected
not being protected and that would mean
that the virus hospitalization and death
figures don't go down as fast
as ministers are hoping for right now no
there are clearly lots of
problems to get this right but i would
have to say that if you're looking from
france or
germany or italy or spain the kind of
problems you'd like to have
yeah right now it's funny that britain
has vaccinated more people than the rest
of europe
put together partly because we started
on december the 8th
and matt hancock when james and i
interviewed him was
basically thinking that what has
happened that we've got a regulator
moving
very fast speed he thinks this will be
the future for britain's
future as a biotech hub he thinks
companies are going to locate
in britain for a favorable experience
with a regulator
but has been able to move far quicker
from its counterparts
in europe so far with the vaccine
despite the problems it's pretty much
good news to date with lots of
challenges ahead
so given it's good news you probably
won't see much of that
in a lot of the media fraser thanks for
that
thanks for all that work on the data hub
with you and your team it's a real go-to
place
if you want to get the latest stats it's
on our website and it's regularly
updated
let's turn to the politics of this
joined by james forsyth our political
editor katie balls our deputy political
editor
james am i right in thinking that
because of this huge leap in cases
in this second wave or third wave
wherever it is
plus a a substantial rise in deaths
the tory lockdown skeptics are a little
less rebellious or inclined to kick out
at the moment
yes i think the rising cases combined
with a vaccine
means that this third lockdown is far
less controversial
on the tory benches than the second one
was i think you look at the current rate
of infections
which is still obviously going to lead
to hospitalizations and deaths and it's
very hard to argue against
a lockdown unless you are you know a
die-hard libertarian in the same way
that there are very few atheists in a
foxhole
there are very few die-hard libertarians
when you know
one in 50 of the population have a virus
have this virus during a pandemic
and i mean but i think the argument on
the tory benches is all shifting to this
question of when do the restrictions
go uh i think that you saw mark harper
who we've had on spectator tv who's the
chair of the covid recovery group you
know pushing matt hancock to say
essentially
once you've vaccinated this 13 odd
million people who are
most vulnerable to dying from kobed
shouldn't
all the restrictions go then i don't
mean they all will go then
but i think when you hit that 28 million
people
which is the whole first phase of the
vaccine when jonathan van tam talked
about
who account for over 90 of both deaths
and hospitalizations
i think that's when you see the
restrictions go
and if you do a bit of crude maths if
you say that we're doing
two million vaccinations a week by the
middle of february which our government
will have to be doing to hit its target
that suggests that by the beginning of
april
you should have managed to vaccinate
those 28 million people or giving them
their first shot to be accurate right
the first one exactly katie the as a
consequence the
the tory back benches are not quite in
the same rebellious
mood against lockdown and restrictions
as they were
in the run-up to christmas yes and we
saw a very small rebellion if you look
at the
retrospective commons vote we had on the
third lockdown
yesterday um you know just around 14
rebels and
and not all of those are tories you had
um you know dep in there
so i think that there is a sense that
this is it's almost stopped being a live
issue on lockdown as james touched on
the debate has moved and i think what's
been really striking is
for example boris johnson had a zoom uh
video call with his mps
on uh the day before this was to be
voted on in the commons
and it had all the ingredients to be a
bit of a horror show for the prime
minister
uh when you had the second national
lockdown something boris johnson has
ultimately said that he didn't plan on
doing there was a really furious
response from tory mps and at the time
uh that was a rebellion over 50 his back
benches said if you do this a third time
you're going to be facing a three-figure
rebellion now it's nowhere near that and
actually in the q a session there were
no questions from tory mps saying
i disagree with the seven week lockdown
instead what's happened is the
conversation has moved to mitigating
some of the effects
to looking at the vaccine roller and i
don't think this is just because of the
vaccine because when we had the vaccine
approved a while back you still had
people like mark harper
um chair of the cobra recovery group
talking about uh
ultimately the fact that they wanted to
have more of an exit strategy i think it
is
to be frank down to the really quite
terrifying data
that means no one wants to take a risk
or at least a very small number dude as
one tory mp described you know
you now have the very hard radicals they
think other people who are opposing
lockdown
that the mainstream debate in the party
is now how many vaccinated before you
can get rid of
restrictions james is it would it be
too dramatic to say that the prime
minister's
future now depends on the successful
rollout of this vaccine i mean i'm
looking at the figures in france
after week one only about 500 people had
been vaccinated that's 500 not 500 000
to 50
500 and even now despite mr macron's
intervention
it's barely around 7 000.
if the british effort now it's already
well over 1.3 so it's not going there
but if it somehow it was to stumble
badly
not to deliver anywhere near the 13
million by the end of february that has
been promised
that would be incredibly politically
damaging wouldn't it
yes and i think for the reasons casey
said you'd see the tory benches explode
with rage
if you were in a situation where the
restrictions had to stay in place
for uh months and months into the second
half of this year
because the vaccine wasn't being rolled
out quick enough
i i think that this vaccine rollout is
crucial to how voters view the
government's entire handling of this
pandemic
and this country's international
reputation
if you are in a situation where this
country in
april may is is beginning to ease
restrictions
while europe is having to keep them in
place because this country has managed
to vaccinate
more people then i think that could
transform
voters views on how the government has
handled the pandemic and this view of
britain in the world i think it would be
an
advert for uh not it would it would make
brexit britain
look like a more successful country than
it currently
does today now i think we've got very
use people are understandably fed up
with all the talk of
world beating things from the government
that haven't turned out to be well
beating such as test and trace
but the uk has two huge advantages in
this vaccine race
the first is the uk has a regulator
approved
domestically produced vaccine that is
logistically easy to distribute
um it only needs to be kept at fridge
temperature which makes it far simpler
than pfizer and moderna
uh in terms of distribution the second
thing is the uk has a public that is
very willing
to take the vaccine according to some
polling there is no population in the
world that is more willing to take the
vaccine so if
you don't have i think one of the things
that is constraining the vaccine rollout
in france you were talking about is the
level of
anti-vaxx sentiment there which has
slowed things down
you don't have that issue here and
interestingly the government's uh the
department of health's internal polling
shows that you know there's been a uh
over 10 point increase in number of
people
keen to take the vaccine since october
so the british public is getting keener
and keener on taking this vaccine
and i think that means that the take-up
rates which fraser was talking about
should be high which would mean that you
should be able to that gives you a
chance to ease up the restrictions
faster so
this really does all turn to turn now on
whether the british state is capable
of rolling this vaccine out at pace
james you
went with fraser to see the secretary of
state for health what did you make of
his
general demeanor i i think as fraser
says the striking thing about matt
hancock is
is how optimistic he is how close he
thinks we are to the to the finish line
and you know you've got nicola sturgeon
the scottish first minister saying that
she's more worried now than she has been
at any point since march
you've obviously got you know a rate of
1 in 50 rate
of infection according to the ons but
matt hancock is convinced that this
vaccine
offers a root out and i think the other
thing i was very struck by was how he
was very clear about two things
first of all he thinks that people are
essentially protected from two to three
weeks after that first shot so this
there is a there is a big move from this
two-shot vaccine
to the first shot is what they consider
to be crucial now
and then the second thing is he was very
clear about the restrictions go when the
vulnerable have been vaccinated this is
not a question of
the restrictions go when you've achieved
herd immunity through vaccination which
would require kind of
70 80 percent of the population to be
vaccinated rather he thinks the
restrictions will go as soon as you've
broken that link between infections
hospitalizations and deaths
it's interesting that the scottish
government doesn't refer to the oxford
vaccine it refers to the
astrazeneca vaccine i wonder why i'll
just leave that to
ponder in the air uh just as nicolas
sturgeon couldn't bring herself when she
did thank the armed forces they were
called our armed forces not
the british armed forces for some reason
that was also dropped fraser back to you
for a final point before we
uh go to the former secretary of state
for health uh
it is interesting how the political
cycle gets increasingly truncated
the you know the papers the media full
of boris johnson's u-turn before
christmas
having said it would be inhuman to
cancel christmas he then canceled it
you draw over that then telling the bbc
uh last sunday that uh schools were
perfectly safe
and then in 24 hours closing schools
and yet it already all seems to be kind
of ancient history
as we have all eyes on the vaccine
i think it does matter because it has a
kind of corrosive effect
on trust these broken promises pile up
and when people hear boris johnson
saying we're going to be
out of this by easter their first
reaction is well we're certainly not
going to be out of this
by easter because he's been proven wrong
so often
now this matters i think not necessarily
at times of national crisis when
code hospital figures are going up so
much as they are right now
but it matters longer term i mean take
nicola sturgeon who you mentioned
earlier she hasn't made broken promises
she's been pretty straight
with scots her performance hasn't been
great on covert but what she hasn't done
is give a long list of promises which
she wouldn't meet
she is under-promised whereas boris
johnson has over-promised his optimism
has been his own greatest enemy and so i
was funny that
before before this came along support
for independence wasn't particularly
high in scotland it hadn't really
changed since brexit
it was only during the pandemic that
people started to contrast
nicolas sturgeon's um record in broken
promises with that of boris johnson
and they concluded that she was the more
dependable leader
so the pandemic has put the union on the
brink
and if boris johnson ever does manage to
get out of the
um the coveted tunnel as he calls it
he'll find nicolas sturgeon waiting for
him with the may
elections in scotland where she's likely
to get a majority and use that majority
to call
for another independence referendum
indeed let's leave it there
james katie fraser thank you for that
i'm
delighted to say we're joined now by
jeremy hunt he's the longest serving
health secretary in england uh he's now
chairs the select committee
uh and is a conservative back venture
jeremy welcome to the program uh good
afternoon
let me ask you this uh clearly the
rollout of the vaccine
is both a a vital medical imperative in
dealing with covert
and it's very important as we've been
saying politically for mr johnson and
his
government what will be the challenges
what are the biggest challenges you
think
the government faces in getting this
role out to 13 million
of the most vulnerable before february
is out
well it is a massive logistical exercise
but we have one big advantage over the
problems that we had with
track and trace and the the contact
tracing and the centralized testing
laboratories last year
which is that we're not using new
infrastructure to do this
we're using our existing network of gps
supplemented by new centers that are
being set up but a lot of it will be the
existing
infrastructure and i'm actually quite
optimistic that the nhs will rise
to the challenge i think that uh the
numbers that have been done
so far are actually very impressive to
have got to more than a million
already and i think the the challenge
we've got
is actually not on the vaccine rollout
it is the question of whether the nhs is
going to fall over
because the health service journal is
saying that
within two weeks london will run out of
intensive care capacity
but we know from previous lockdowns with
this
virus there's a three-week delay between
doing something big like a lockdown
and it actually feeding through into
hospital admissions
and that is too long when it comes to
london
so um i think it's going to be a very
very nail-biting
next few weeks is is it too late
to do anything about that hospital
capacity now is it
inevitable that in the next couple of
weeks we'll get to where you described
okay
is there emergency action that can be
taken there is
and i don't actually think we will get
to the point where
uh someone who needs an intensive care
bed doesn't
get one because the nhs at the moment is
will be scrabbling around frantically to
try and source those extra beds whether
from the private sector whether from
neighboring trusts and i think they'll
do it but what i don't think will happen
is that we will i don't think we'll be
able to avoid the knock-on effects on
things like cancer care
um maybe some people who might have been
sent to intensive care or borderline
case
in previous times won't get sent this
time
who knows you know the outcome might not
be as good for that person so i'm afraid
the kind of knock-on effects that we saw
in the first
lockdown in terms of the impact on other
nhs care
will be very severe the government has
been widely criticized over the months
for its handling of the whole culvert
crisis
every government's been criticized but
mr johnson's government has come in for
more than most is is the vaccine is get
out of jail card does that is it the
does the vaccine overwhelm
all the other criticisms i think he
could i
i'd rather agree with james's analysis
just now
um we were too slow to go into lockdown
too slow to adopt uh test and trace as a
methodology
but we have been the best in the world
at approving vaccines and in terms of
distributing them just behind israel so
better than any other comparably sized
country and i think
we can say with a lot of pride it wasn't
just the brilliance of british science
and of course the fisa vaccine wasn't
developed in this country but the
obviously the oxford astrazeneca one i'm
going to put the word oxford in even if
nicola sturgeon won't
uh it was and i think that may turn out
to be the best vaccine
as it happens but actually government
decisions
i mean matt hancock set up the vaccine
task force with kate bingham you know
that had controversy in the early days
he made a big play gambling
on pre-buying quantities huge quantities
of different types of
vaccines and those gambles paid off
and that was a ministerial decision and
he should get a lot of credit for that
so i think if this works out people will
say well
we had a very tough pandemic we didn't
get it all right but we got some things
very right and if we're the first
country to get back to normal
that will be a very very big philip for
the government
i think most people regard this as a
national effort almost like a wartime
effort to roll out this
vaccine and then it has to be all hands
to the deck
that's understandable so what do you
make then of when
we hear that public health england says
it won't work on sundays
i do think that's extraordinary i'm a
little bit hesitant
to to pile in until i actually know
that's true
but if it is true and if i had been a
minister
i would have been uh sending that
recommendation right back and saying
what on earth are you talking about this
is absolute nonsense
and has the government i mean it has
seemed that
time and again the government has been
behind the curve i think it's a
criticism
you have made of them too particularly
when it comes to lockdown
is that because of mr johnson's kind of
natural libertarian instincts that he's
always been reluctant to do
what he's ended up having to do as we've
seen this week
i think it may be that and in some ways
i think that because of those instincts
when we do finally do a lockdown there's
quite a lot of public support for it
because people do
recognize this is not something the
government has rushed into
um and i think there are genuine issues
if i mean i think we should have gone in
earlier
and actually even this week i i think we
should have made the decision last week
because i'm not really sure what data
was
only available on monday that we
couldn't have seen on thursday or friday
of last week
but nonetheless uh he you know on monday
he had a meeting on monday afternoon he
made the decision we went
bang into lockdown from the following
morning that is a whole lot quicker than
the
speed that decisions were made at the
start of the pandemic
where are we equipped to deal with this
i mean clearly not when you look at
what's happened but
you were a sexual state for health when
this uh operation
cygnus the the pandemic war game uh was
carried out
uh and it was a very extensive war game
and i read quite a lot about it
but it wasn't for a covert type pandemic
it was it was the wrong war game wasn't
it that's exactly
the point i mean all the recommendations
that were made to ministers
following that pandemic were implemented
and there were some that were very
useful for this pandemic for example
drafting the emergency powers
legislation that was a
pretty important piece of work that came
out which we sadly did have to put into
practice but if you look through that
report
there is not a mention anywhere of
testing not once
and that kind of sums up that we were
not just in this country but across the
whole of europe and america
there was this group think that pandemic
equals flu pandemic and
you know looking back on it you have to
say
you know we had sars in 2002 murs in
2014
they happen to be in other parts of the
world but
i think it's very important we set up
structures now
to make sure that that group think of
which i was part
doesn't take hold going forward well
let's go forward a little bit finally uh
jeremy hunt uh from what you've been
saying
it seems possible that if we get the 13
million roll out to the most vulnerable
groups
by the end of february we will after
that begin to see
the death rate and the case numbers
begin to fall we can then get more a lot
more than 13 million
and it may not be pie in the sky to
think
that sometime after easter which is very
early this
year in april there could be
not an event that's a return to
normality
but the beginnings of a process that
heads towards
some semblance of normality well i'm an
optimist and i've booked a family
holiday for the summer half term which
is the first week of june so
um i very much hope that uh i don't have
to get another of these bloody vouchers
that the airlines give you when you
cancel your
your tickets but i um i do think there
is a lot of risk
and i think we've just got to recognize
the most important
thing is something we're going to hear
in the next two weeks
which are the results of the test which
they're doing public health england are
doing important down at the moment which
say whether the vaccine works
against the new kent strain
and then about a week after that we
should hear whether the vaccine works
against the south african strain
and that is the bit of information that
i am really waiting for before i start
banking everything on easter good thing
we'll look out for that
and uh we all hope you get your holiday
at the beginning
of june as well jeremy hunt thank you
for joining us here on spectator
tv that's it for this week thanks to all
of our guests and once again to our very
special sponsor charles
stanley who's a continuing to sponsor
the week in 60 minutes charles stanley
is one of the uk's leading wealth
management firms one of the oldest firms
on the london stock exchange we're
delighted to have them as our partners
a final reminder that if you subscribe
to the spectators
youtube channel and it doesn't cost a
penny you'll never miss another episode
you just
click the subscribe button at the bottom
of the screen
right now and as always please send any
thoughts to spectator tv
at spectator dot co dot uk join us again
next week bye bye
[Music]
you